en el último vídeo hice una introducción
a lo que es el operador la playa no en
el contexto de la función con esta
gráfica y con su campo gradiente verdad
que se dibuja abajo en este vídeo quiero
calcular el aplazado de esta función así
que vamos a venir aquí a la pantalla
negro y nosotros tenemos que esta
función era la función
efe de cayey la que vimos en el vídeo
anterior y era 3 + coseno de x entre 2
por el seno de g
sobre 2 esta era la función que teníamos
verdad y entonces lo que queremos hacer
es calcular el aplasia no de nuestra
función
efe muy bien que por supuesto vimos en
el vídeo anterior que esto se calcula
como este operador no habla si hacemos
el producto punto con el gradiente de
nuestra función
efe muy bien entonces primero tenemos
que ver quién es el gradiente de nuestra
función
efe verdad entonces nosotros sabemos muy
bien cómo calcular el gradiente
esencialmente pensamos
digamos en habla verdad como una especie
de vector donde tiene los operadores de
las derivadas parciales verdad y
entonces tendríamos que multiplicar con
este vector a nuestra función f y por
supuesto cuando decimos multiplicar nos
referimos a que vamos a hacer la
derivada parcial en cada acorde nada
digamos verdad sabemos que esto es
puramente notación al verdad no no es no
es algo muy riguroso entonces esto es
digamos aquí esta multiplicación sería
la derivada parcial con respecto de x de
nuestra función f y luego tendremos acá
abajo la derivada parcial con respecto
de ye de nuestra función f verdad y esto
sería el gradiente de nuestra función
ahora bien para este caso particular
como se calcula bueno pues tendríamos
que calcular las derivadas parciales y
ponerlas en este vector verdad así que
si nosotros derivamos esto de aquí con
respecto de x bueno 3 simplemente es una
constante así que se anula y ahora hay
que derivar coseno
x entre 2 entonces por regla de la
cadena vamos a tener un medio verdad un
medio que sale de esta parte digamos en
donde estamos evaluando la función y
luego tenemos que calcular la derivada
del coseno por la derivada del coce no
es menos el seno de lo que sea que
teníamos adentro x entre 2 verdad y
ahora en realidad todavía tenemos que
multiplicar por este término que en
realidad es como una constante para
fines de derivar con respecto de x
verdad entonces esto es la primera
derivada verdad la derivada parcial
respecto de x y ahora si nosotros
queremos derivar con respecto de y bueno
este 13 sigue anulando verdad esto sería
una constante y en realidad hay que
derivar esta parte entonces la derivada
del seno de medios sería un medio verdad
otra vez por regla de la cadena que
multiplica a la derivada del seno que es
coseno de lo que sea que teníamos
adentro y en medios y esto multiplica al
coseno de x entre 2 que es justamente la
parte
para fines de derivar con respecto de
que entonces aquí ya hemos obtenido lo
que es el gradiente de nuestra función
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular la divergencia de este campo
vectorial que ya hemos obtenido entonces
recordemos que en la divergencia verdad
se calcula justamente como un producto
punto en donde otra vez tenemos nuestro
nuestro vector nab la verdad que es un
vector con estos operadores
diferenciales y hacemos el producto
punto con esto que ya teníamos
anteriormente simplemente voy a copiarlo
y pegarlo muy bien y lo ponemos de este
lado muy bien así que el recordemos que
el producto punto es como una especie de
multiplicación coordenada por coordenada
verdad entonces lo que tendríamos es que
vamos a hacer esta especie de
multiplicación y luego sumamos la otra
multiplicación y donde hablamos de
multiplicación en realidad significa
aplicar este operador a esta expresión
verdad entonces si nosotros utilizamos
la derivada parcial respecto de x de
esta expresión bueno pues vamos a tener
un medio un medio que multiplica a la
derivada de menos seno de x entre 2 con
respecto de x verdad entonces de aquí va
a salir otro medio por regla de la
cadena verdad y ahora tendríamos que
calcular la derivada de menos seno de x
entre 2 que sería menos coseno de x
sobre 2 verdad y en realidad este
término queda igual multiplicando porque
es una constante a la hora de derivar
con respecto de x entonces este es
nuestro primer término y ahora hacemos
este producto verdad que es evaluar la
derivada parcial respecto de y de esta
expresión y la sumamos porque es como
una especie de producto punto entonces
aquí teníamos un medio verdad y al
derivar respecto de que vamos a obtener
otro medio verdad pero al derivar cocina
de medios tendríamos menos el seno de
medios
y este término es constante a la hora de
derivar con respecto de ella así que se
queda como coseno de x medios y aquí lo
tenemos esta es la fórmula de la plastia
no para la función que estábamos con la
que estábamos trabajando verdad y por
supuesto que podríamos seguir
simplificando pero el punto de este
vídeo es simplemente mostrar el proceso
para calcular en la plaza no en donde
tomamos inicialmente el gradiente de
nuestra función luego tomamos la
divergencia de ese campo vectorial que
obtenemos y esencialmente lo que
obtenemos es la plaza no nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo